So we've got something really exciting to tell you about a paper that came out
during the lockdown. It's actually a physics paper,
but it's about a new form of nitrogen.
The element nitrogen and people are already calling it black
nitrogen. I'll explain why in a minute,
but before you get too excited about having your own
sample,
it can only be made at a pressure of 1.4 million
atmospheres.
That's 1.4 million times higher pressure than
that atmospheric pressure and the surface and the temperature
a bit over 4,000 degrees Celsius, right?
So it's not an experiment you can do in your kitchen,
nitrogen.
And two exists as a gas at room temperature.
And if you cool it down, it forms a liquid.
And so chemists everywhere are only familiar with the gas or liquid
nitrogen. If you only really cold,
you can also get to solid,
but most chemist have never seen solid nitrogen phosphorus.
On the other hand,
which is in the same group of the periodic table immediately underneath
nitrogen phosphorus has three different forms,
has a white form, which is rarely reactive.
You've seen Pete burning it.
And then we'll watch what happens.
So instantaneously, you can see that fantastic oxidation reaction.
Red phosphorus,
which is a sort of reddish Brown color and black phosphorus,
which I'd never seen till a couple of years ago when I was giving a lecture in
the German city often when I was a bit worried before the
lecture and walking round,
I saw a case with a sample of black phosphorus,
and I photographed it for you, the periodic videos viewers,
and as the first time for me to show you and you can see it really is black.
Now in black phosphorus,
the atoms of phosphorus are arranged in rings.
Hexagonal rings that are joined together like the wire in
chicken wire, but unlike chicken wire, they're not flat,
but they go up and down because of the angles between the
bonds and the phosphorus nobody has ever before
seen nitrogen in this form.
So nobody has seen nitrogen with this structure
though, in theory, nitrogen could form that.
But usually the reason that I and everybody else teaches our
students is that end too,
has the strongest possible bond between two atoms or so-called triple
bond.
And any other form of nitrogen would decompose to form
into gas with a huge release of energy.
So you've already seen on some of our videos when reactions form and
two, they release a lot of energy,
our famous bulking dog experiment,
and rocket fuels. You've seen our rocket tension
And the decomposition of nitrogen triad date.
They all form nitrogen and release energy.
Now this experiment,
which was explained in the paper was performed in Germany
by a group,
led by a scientist called Dominique [inaudible]
. They have built a very special piece of operators that will generate really high pressures. And the operators consists of two pieces of diamond, which are tapered. So they go to a very narrow point. And the end of the point is flattened. When you press the fat ends of the diamonds, you amplify the pressure. So you can generate a really high pressure between the tips between the tips. They put a very thin sheet of the metal rhenium, and they drilled
a tiny hole, only 40 microns thinner than when the may has in that
toe is where they did the experiment. They have a machine for generating pressure. They fill it by putting a very high pressure of nitrogen round, the whole operators about 1200 atmospheres.
So quite high pressure of nitrogen.
And as they start squeezing the nitrogen solidifies,
and when it's solid, it is not very compressible.
So they can ramp up the pressure very easily, that type, they get the pressure,
but how did they heat it?
And the way they heat it is to shine a laser beam,
a very intense laser beam through the diamond onto the
sample.
And the laser beam can deliver a lot of energy very quickly and heat up the end
into before they have melted the whole of the operators, right?
And when they heat it up, the nitrogen bones get broken.
The atoms get really hot,
give out a lot of light because they're just so hot.
You'll know how red top things give out.
And this is much hotter than red hot. When the bones are broken,
they can reform in a different way. And how do they form?
What happens what's happened is that at a
pressure of about 1.2 million atmospheres,
the nitrogen is actually black. And this is the exciting thing.
When they heat it up at 1.4 million atmospheres,
it suddenly goes transparent.
So they have the sample of transparent nitrogen under
really high pressure. And the question is,
how do you find that what this transparent stuff is made of?
How are the nitrogen atoms arranged.
After they've done the experiment and they've had the high pressure and the
laser, and everything's turned off,
does the nitrogen stay in its solid form.
Once it's formed, at least for the time of the experiment,
everything is stable. How much.
If they made like a thimble fall or like how much do you make in this little
avoid?
Well, you have a hole that is 40 microns in
diameter,
and the rhenium starts at 200
microns thick and get squashed.
So there's really very, very little, you know,
normally we talk about cubic centimeters or
milliliters here.
We're talking about the Pico liter or perhaps even less.
So a tiny, tiny amount. So the question is,
how do you find out what it is?
And they have two different ways of doing it the first way is that
they've taken their operators to a so-called
synchrotron.
This is a very large piece of equipment and electronic
accelerator,
which produces very intense pulses of x-rays.
And you can use those x-rays to look at
the structure of crystals and the
tiny piece of nitrogen transparent nitrogen they've made
is the crystal. What happens when they shine?
The x-rays onto the crystal is that the
x-rays are diffracted to a series of spots.
Rather light light is diffracted from the back of the CD or
DVD from the pattern of these spots,
they can compute what the structure of the solid
was that different. Did the x-rays have they.
Carried the crystal from where they did the experiment to the synchrotron,
or do they do the experiment at the synchrotron or is the crystal stable enough
that you can put it in a container and carry it around.
The experiments done in the synchrotron?
And as far as I know,
they take the diffraction pattern as quickly as they can,
after they've heated with the laser.
And there's some nice pictures that Dominique sent to us showing the
equipment in situ at the synchrotron,
it looks so complicated. I don't even quite know which way the beam goes,
but it's pretty impressive.
And what did that synchrotron tell them what had they created?
What the synchrotron told them was that the
structure of the nitrogen they had formed was exactly the
same structure as the structure of black phosphorous,
which is why they called them material B P
N BP for black phosphorus and then N for nitrogen.
So there's no actual phosphorus in there.
The BP just stands for this is like black phosphorus.
Yes, precisely no phosphorus in it at all.
It just has the same structure. Some journalists who've reported it,
simplified it and called it black nitrogen,
which is a bit silly since it's transparent and the light can get through.
It was black for awhile. And then it went transparent. What's that about.
The solid nitrogen from which it's formed is black
because it has some other structure.
And I don't know precisely why it's black,
but the fact that the BP nitrogen is colorless is
really interesting.
They believe the reason is the 10 black phosphorous,
which is really black,
the bonds between each phosphorous item of the same length,
but in the nitrogen form,
some of the nitrogen atoms are closer together than other ones.
And this means that the electrons in the black
nitrogen is arranged in a different way from the electrons
in black phosphorous and for physicists. That's really very good.
So professor, I can see what the physicists are excited,
just because they've seen something for the first time,
but is there any usefulness to this or applications like with graphene and
things like that?
I think the answer is that there's no application for
black nitrogen as it is,
but it might have some use
because in the sense,
the tip will allow people to understand the behavior of nitrogen
and allow them to design new materials,
which contain some nitrogen and perhaps some phosphorus or some other element
so that they get different electronic properties.
But from the point of view of chemists,
I think it is very interesting because we,
as chemists usually don't think very much about high
pressures for us.
200 atmospheres is already a really high pressure.
And we never really think much about how our elements
behave when there is a million atmosphere's pressure.
And so I think what this experiment will do
is make me be slightly less dogmatic when I say
nitrogen only exist as in too.
And for some of you who are away from school because of
lockdown, when you go back, you can say to your teachers,
you're wrong. There isn't just, and two,
there's a new form that's been discovered.
Raising and liquid nitrogen. I'd never tried freezing a banana.